sean you're a fine host because you just
asked the right question we do this
over and over and over again
they testify they say we're looking into
it we'll get back to you on that we'll
circle back to you
all of the stuff that we know they're
never going to do i think these
companies
have grown so large that they they're
not too big to fail they're too big to
succeed in a weird way now they've
succeeded in that they've made
shareholders money
uh but they've failed in that the lack
of transparency is so
obvious and so painful especially for
anyone that is
non-woke i don't even have to say
conservative if you're just non-woke you
know you're going to be de-boosted
or shadow banned or algorithmically
manipulated or the series of other
orwellian terms that we've all now
come to know but the idea that congress
is going to do anything about any of
this at this point
i think the ship has sailed on that i
think there are technological answers i
think
that we are going to need to lead on the
forefront of of
new answers related to tech and there's
going to be some murky waters to travail
but congress they don't want to do
anything they're afraid of these people
in essence so
it's a dog and pony show yeah i totally
agree the thing that's so interesting is
i i don't think the
the democrats basically say you know we
should we should have more censorship
essentially like
we should let not let people spread
misinformation even though
you know in some cases it's actually
just people's opinion right
but then the republicans actually really
do care about
people getting canceled out and we saw
that for the most part people go well
they're private entities
if you don't like it go start your own
and parlor went and did that
right and then when they felt threatened
what did they do they deplatformed
and i'm trying to figure out if you're
on the right i don't think that the ceos
even care
right they basically every time that
someone on the right gets shadow banned
or their account gets locked they go
it was just a mistake on the algorithm
it's always a mistake it's always
interesting
these algorithms these algorithms make
an awful lot of mistakes that always
point in the same direction i'm not a
private investigator but i think
something might be up
but you make an interesting point about
parlor because yes parlor came in
they signed up about 21 million people
that's an extraordinary amount of new
users onto their system
and then in essence after what happened
on the capital on january 6
amazon just blew up their servers that
was a massive
escalation of this of this big tech war
as you know i've started my own tech
company called locals.com and i and
we're trying to solve as many of the
problems as possible
we're building people digital homes so
that you sean or me or anyone watching
this can build their own digital home
and then what you do in your home is up
to you much like
you know somebody built my house but
what goes on in my house is not his
responsibility
uh of course we have a basic set of
terms of service and you can't break the
laws of the united states
can you i was going to ask you about
this this is because locals.com you did
this
so people would have a home right and i
wanted to ask you like how do you draw
the line
like because i think the question is if
you express an opinion
a lot of times facebook or youtube will
say
that's that's misinformation right um
where do you
how do you figure this how do you draw
the line and figure out where's the
first amendment right for someone to
express their opinion
up until the point where they're either
spreading misinformation
or or violently threatening someone or
whatever
sure so our policy is that you can't
break the laws of the united states you
can't post pornography and you know some
direct threats i mean really stuff that
we all know
um you know is is against most terms of
service
but beyond that what happens in your own
locals community so mine is
reubenreport.locals.com
it's up to the creator and and one of
the things that we've done to really
build a nice system
is that there is a paywall to get in as
a creator you pick the paywall that you
want it could be a couple bucks a month
to to whatever you want it to be
and by people putting a little skin in
the game literally as little as two
dollars
that eliminates virtually all of the bad
behavior so my community has existed for
about two years now the company's about
two and a half years old
and i think i've banned one person
because he was just there to troll me
and i said all right i don't want to
make money from you but the beauty is
we're not
kicking him out of the system because he
can still be in other people's locals
community and again that's why
i say we're building digital homes where
facebook and twitter and youtube they
decided to build
basically uh open spaces for everybody
and then once everybody got in they
decided to say hey these places aren't
really open
so it's a fundamental shift in thinking
and we also have to remember
that if you're not paying for something
you're the product
and we all spend virtually all day long
on this thing right many of us spend
more than half of our day more than 12
hours of our day on this thing
well it might be stealing a little
something from us and it's our it's our
information it's our data and it's our
souls yes that's exactly right
they're it's not free they're getting
our data
right and that's the thing um again
locals.com right
locals.com yeah that's the beauty of
this i love what you're doing because
this is what it's all supposed to be
you're supposed to be able to share your
opinion your idea maybe you're
wrong maybe you're right maybe you
evolve but the idea is to have free
speech sean you're not going to believe
this but i don't think the government
can save me
i it's crazy right like i believe in
human ingenuity that's not to say that
the government doesn't have any role in
anything we've discussed this many times
you can talk about regulation we could
talk about maybe breaking up some of
these companies i think
you have to use all of the tools we
could look at legal tools related to
their
the section 230 and everything else but
what i what i my
overarching belief is that humans and
ingenuity
and the blockchain and decentralized
storage and payments all of those things
will stop this
believe me whatever clown tomorrow at
congress is going to ask jack dorsey
or mark zuckerberg something that they
know nothing about is not going to come
to me later with a piece of paper and go
ah i solved all those big tech
problems if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about tech instead of non-stop yelling
check out our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell